I think we can always do more I always
do more it's a huge humanitarian crisis
and we can I have to step up to the
plate I don't think we're doing enough
and I think there should be more people
taken out take it take it in and I think
that at least double the amount um
because these are people exactly like we
are yeah we can always do more yeah I
think you sure yeah of course it's just
how that's done you know whether it's
done at source in the countries where
the refugees are coming from or whether
it's done in terms of welcoming people
into this country and providing housing
and support for them I don't know I
don't know the answer I don't you can
ever do enough we as a country you know
I've got a lot of thinking to do about
about how you'd if we define ourselves
you know but i think it's it's crazy to
think there are people out there who who
need shelter and you know and and can't
get it in this country the country's
made up of people who have come from
other places fleeing awful things and
have brought a lot to this country so
the fear-mongering i find i find really
disturbing and some of the language I
find disturbing I mean Italy they are
doing so much but they're also in France
they're really fighting and i have a
friend of mine and actually he gave his
song and two for refugees so I think
there are people that I am really doing
so many things